der exoplanet k2 18b könnte
möglicherweise flüssiges wasser
beherbergen und somit lebensfreundliche
bedingungen bieten fachleute haben die
rund 124 lichtjahre entfernte supererde
und das ist nicht weit weg genauer ins
visier genommen und dabei festgestellt
dass außerirdisches leben auf deutlich
mehr himmelskörpern vorstellbar ist als
bislang gedacht klicks um science
fiction die gibt's täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
er nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
immer mehr spricht dafür das leben nicht
nur die ausnahme sondern vielleicht doch
der normalfall im universum ist immer
mehr indizien sprechen dafür und jetzt
auch dieser exoplanet die supererde k2
18b hat den 2,6 fache nähert radios die
rund 8 fache masse unseres
heimatplaneten und liegt etwa 124
lichtjahre von uns entfernt fachleute
sprechen von der sogenannten habitablen
zone
damit sind die umlaufbahnen um sterne
gemeint in denen leben auf planeten
prinzipiell möglich ist denn in dieser
habitablen zone kann wasser fließen und
wasser ist die grundvoraussetzung
überhaupt für leben somit darf ein
planet also nicht so nah aber auch nicht
zu weit weg von seinem zentralgestirn
sein der ich zum planet k2 18b hatte im
vergangenen jahr für aufregung gesorgt
denn forschende konnten in seiner
gashülle wassermoleküle nachweisen eine
sensation und eine echte premiere
die supererde k2 18 ist somit nämlich
der erste exoplanet in der habitablen
zone bei dem astronomie teams
wassermoleküle in der gashülle finden
konnten dies deutet darauf hin dass sich
darunter wasser und möglicherweise sogar
ein lebensfeindlicher ozean befinden
könnte doch das war bislang nur eine
vermutung denn bis heute konnte nicht
ausgeschlossen werden dass die gashülle
dieser supererde viel zu dick ist so
würde der gewaltige druck die existenz
von flüssigem wasser unmöglich machen
bisher weiß die wissenschafts community
nur eines cuts 18b weist eine dichte von
2 67 gramm pro kubikzentimeter aus und
dies entspricht genau dem grenzbereich
zwischen eisigen gasplaneten wie neptun
und gesteinsplaneten hat der exoplaneten
also eine dünne atmosphäre mit einem
dickeren flüssigen ozean oder aber
besteht aus einem
kleinen festen kern mit einer riesigen
gashülle im klartext lautet die frage
aller fragen also kann wasser unter der
atmosphäre existieren oder nicht diesem
rätsel ist jetzt ein us forschungsteam
nachgegangen dazu der wissenschaftler
nico motto sudan der an der aktuellen
studie beteiligt war
um die aussichten für die habit amelete
dieses planeten einschätzen zu können
ist es wichtig seinen inneren aufbau und
die atmosphärischen bedingungen des
planeten zu kennen
dazu erstellten die fachleute eine
simulation und verschiedene modelle und
das ergebnis ist eindeutig auch wenn der
ex internet eine große masse aufweist
ist es keineswegs ausgeschlossen dass
ein flüssiger ozean auf ihm existiert
die modelle zeigen dass dies sogar bei
mehreren kombinationen von kern masse
und dicke der gashülle denkbar ist diese
erkenntnis hat spektakuläre folgen dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam das zitat
das potenzial für habitablen bedingungen
nicht notwendigerweise auf erdähnliche
gesteinsplaneten beschränkt ist und das
heißt im klartext dass auf deutlich mehr
himmelskörpern als bislang angenommen
außerirdisches leben möglich sein könnte
fachleute sehen in diesem zusammenhang
vor allem die vielen exoplaneten im
grenzbereich zwischen mini neptun und
den super erden
dadurch erweitert sich das spektrum für
die suche nach außerirdischem leben also
enorm und die genaue analyse der
supererde k2 18b offenbarte weitere
spannende erkenntnisse die fachleute
gehen von deutlich höheren
konzentrationen an methan und ammoniak
aus als die spektral daten offenbarten
das ist laut dem forschungsteam eine
große überraschung bei einer
wasserstoffreichen atmosphäre mit rund
26 grad sollten jedoch methan und
ammoniak die dominanten kohlenstoff
träger sein wenn ein chemisches
gleichgewicht besteht heißt also dass
das gleichgewicht der gashülle gestört
ist wodurch auch immer denkbar sind hier
nicht nur physikalische sondern auch
biologische prozesse das müssen nun
weitere untersuchungen zeigen
es bleibt also weiter spannend gliese
581 g leben auf exoplaneten zu 100
anklicken anschauen und astro comics tv
unbedingt abonnieren sehr cooler kanal
bis dann bleibt dran